approchez approchez la cité
d'archéologie et d'histoire de montréal
pointe à callière vous avez entré sous
le chapiteau et à découvrir l'histoire
fascinante des arts du cirque une
histoire qui a à peu près de 150 ans en
étant de 768 en angleterre fait les
passes les qui développe un premier
cirque en dur où il invite des écuyers à
faire des acrobaties et ça suscite
l'attrait des foules des de cette
période au québec 10 797 un premier
cirque permanent à montréal avec le john
by brick est ce qui vient s'installer
dans le vieux-montréal tout près de
pointe à callière
l'exposition place au cirque présente
350 objets variés qui témoignent de
l'évolution du cirque d'hier à
aujourd'hui et de sa place dans
l'imaginaire collectif
vous imaginez la ménagerie les éléphants
les girafes qui arrivent dans les chars
allégoriques
coloré avec des personnages absolument
fabuleux ça donc ça attirait beaucoup la
curiosité et ça leur a aussi allumé la
flamme chez certains jeunes québécois
effectivement rapidement des troupes
québécoises se lance dans l'aventuré on
va alors voir le développement de
différentes familles qui vont tirer des
cirques qui vont se déplacer soit aux
états unis ou au canada dont le premier
est louis cyr dont il sera le premier
entrepreneur donc avoir sa propre troupe
le parcours thématique et chronologique
nous permet de découvrir les avancées
qui ont mené aux types de cirque que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui
l'exposition se termine par un hommage à
cette troupe québécoise contemporaine
qui partagent un langage commun mais qui
ont des esthétiques bien différente de
quoi changer notre vision du monde
circassien c'est prendre conscience que
le cirque est universel qu'il a généré
des oeuvres littéralement qu'il a généré
des témoignages plastiques graphiques
esthétique et que donc on est bien loin
simplement d'un spectacle pour se
divertir c'est ça aussi mais je pense
que le site recèle une part de notre
mémoire collective en tant qu'humanité
place au cirque une exposition qui fera
pousser des ora aux petits et aux grands
qui ont gardé leur quart d'enfants ici
n'est bien l'ex andré chartier radio
canada montréal